the internet just can't let it go Elsa
all anyone can talk about is your love
life frozen fans have so many theories
about your character in the new movie
people are certain that they have you
all figured out but you're the strongest
Disney royalty we've ever seen so we're
pretty sure you're going to surprise us
with whatever decision you make and
we'll stand by your side no matter what
we've never doubted you for a second
Elsa there are tons of theories about
Elsa's love life in frozen - but some
fans aren't convinced that the ice
princess is going to fall in love stay
tuned to find out the truth about else's
personal life I love you the plot of
frozen to Disney has been giving us
little hints about the plot of frozen -
here's what we know so far
Elsa Anna Kristoff Olaf and Sven set out
on a journey that takes them far from
arendelle there is some great threat to
their Kingdom and finding the source of
Elsa's powers will help them save their
people
Disney is being pretty tight-lipped
about the rest of it we also know that
Evan Rachel Wood will be voicing Idina
in the new movie I do know was the name
of Elsa and Ana's mother will she only
be seen in flashbacks we don't know but
we do know that Hans is set to return as
Santino Fontana is listed as a cast
member again we don't know if that's
just a flashback or not we also know
that sterling K Brown is joining the
cast but his character has not yet been
revealed the trailer reveals a boy in
the young woman with brown hair the
trailer doesn't directly mention that
Elsa will have a love story so does the
ice queen fall in love Elsa the past is
not what it seems
the girlfriend hypothesis the give Elsa
a girlfriends movement goes back several
years the hashtag started back in 2016
when Disney announced that they would be
making frozen to but this van theory
goes back to the original movie in 2013
Elsa is only one of a few Disney
princesses and queens to have no love
story Merida from brave was the first
and mallanna also had no time for dating
but frozen still had an adorable love
story between Kristoff and Anna lots of
people thought that else's song let it
go was an anthem for coming out and that
led to a ton of speculation that Elsa
was the first gay Disney main character
lots of people have been begging Disney
to give Elsa a girlfriend and frozen to
the actress who plays her idina menzel
has said she would be totally on board
with it Wow what power do you have to
stop this winter but the director and
writer Jennifer Lee won't give a clear
answer
she says that Elsa is telling her where
to take the story the frozen to trailer
features a young woman who seems to have
wind related powers she has dark hair
and many fans are convinced that this is
Elsa's new love interest others think
that this is just Anna with a new look I
came for the Queen plenty of other fans
think that Disney isn't quite ready to
make such a controversial casting
decision and everyone is on board with
the idea of Elsa having a girlfriend and
we can't rule out the possibility that
Elsa will actually meet and fall in love
with a man there's a new girl in the
teaser trailer but there is also a boy
we don't get to see him for more than a
split second but who is he sterling K
Brown will be voicing a new male
character in the sequel is he the one
who will catch Elsa's eye we also know
that Hans is returning either in a
flashback or as part of the plot Oh
Prince Hans of the Southern Isles now
there's no way Elsa would fall for
someone as evil as Hans but Hans does
have 12 brothers that means there are 12
more possibilities for a king of
arendelle no time for love the last
possibility for Elsa's love life is that
she just doesn't have one let's look at
the facts in the first frozen movie Elsa
was more than willing to spend her life
alone in her ice castle love was as far
from her mind as ruling arendelle was
now that she has accepted her
role as Queen she is one busy lady and
it looks like there is plenty to keep
her distracted and frozen too there is
some unknown threat to her kingdom she
has to go on a long journey she's trying
to master freezing the ocean and she
needs to find the source of her powers
to save the world honestly where could
she find time for love and Elsa doesn't
need a love interest she is incredibly
powerful she is brilliant and she's got
great support from her family and
friends if Elsa doesn't get a love
interest it's a whole new type of
representation more and more people are
realizing that they don't have to fall
in love and get married to be happy it's
just not for everyone
Disney has been giving us love stories
for decades everyone knows the trope of
living happily ever after once you get
the prince but in 2019 people have lots
of different ideas about happily ever
afters else it could be yet another
example of a strong independent woman
who doesn't want a love story Wow Elsa
you look different
it's a good difference we think any of
these three theories about Elsa's love
life could work what do you think is the
truth about else's love interest tell us
all your favourite frozen to fan
theories in the comment section below
also sluff story revealed in frozen too
thanks for watching be sure to give us a
big thumbs up and subscribe to the
things to never miss another video we'll
see you later
[Music]